polio once crippled hundreds of
thousands of children every year a
global eradication campaign begun in
1988 has reduced that figure to hundreds
and the virus now circulates in only
three countries Pakistan Afghanistan and
here in Nigeria to stamp out the polio
virus for good these countries not
nationwide immunization campaigns on a
near monthly basis locally trained
health workers identified by their blue
aprons fan out to cities towns and
villages giving simple oral vaccines to
as many young children as they can find
despite these efforts some children are
never reached by the vaccination teams
in hard-to-reach patches of northern
Nigeria the children of nomadic cattle
and sheep herders are particularly
susceptible to polio what's more their
migrations may spread the virus around
Nigeria and Beyond preventing polio from
being wiped out
I'm nature reporter you and Callaway I
traveled to Nigeria to search for
nomadic communities with a team of
epidemiologists the nomads belonged to a
cultural group called the Fulani and
twice a year they trekked cross-country
in December when I visited some nomadic
families had already begun their
migration south in search of greener
pastures for their animals the
epidemiologists I was with used
satellite imaging to get an idea where
the nomads live but reaching these
settlements is another matter off-road
motorbikes were a must the team works
with local guides but they don't always
know where exactly to find the nomadic
settlements so we sometimes had to stop
and ask for directions
each family has their own Bruegel a
collection of mud brick huts and their
relatives often live in neighboring
settlements a few hundred meters away
the team arrived with a local Fulani
leader he introduced us to the head of
the household and told him we were
trying to eradicate polio among nomads
the team is working on building a map of
every pneumatic settlement they find
they also record the number of young
children in the settlement and whether
or not they have been vaccinated before
hamid abu bakar a fulani nomads told us
that he could not remember anyone ever
coming to his rouga to vaccinate his
children in the past year
epidemiologists have mapped more than
30,000 settlements and identified over
700 thousand young children living in
nomadic and other remote communities
here the goal is that nomadic
communities will be included in national
polio immunization campaigns and that
children like Abu Bakr's will be
vaccinated routinely the global polio
eradication effort has lasted twenty
five years and cost over ten billion
dollars becoming one of the costliest
and longest-running public health
efforts in history
if polio is to become a thing of the
past
then countries like Nigeria will have to
stamp out the virus from its final
hideouts no matter how difficult they
are to find